من موقع الانفجار بالضاحيه الجنوبيه
لبيروت ينضم الينا جوني طانيوس مراسل
الجزيره جوني اخر المشاهدات والمعلومات
بشان عمليه الاغتيال لصالح
العروي يمكن القول حسن ان المعلومات
تتوالى وترتسم الصوره بشكل اوضح مع تقدم
الوقت بشان ما حصل في هذا الشارع في منطقه
المشرفيه في الضاحيه الجنوبيه لبيروت يمكن
القول ان المشهد ما يزال على حاله
لناحيه كميه الاجهزه المعنيه بمتابعه هذا
الوضع الحاضره في هذا المكان اكان من قبل
الاجهزه الرسميه الامنيه اللبنانيه الجيش
اللبناني الادله الجنائيه الاجهزه الاغاثه
من دفاع مدني وغيرها من الاجهزه هي حاضره
هنا طبعا للقيام بكل عمليات المسح اللازمه
وازاله ما يمكن ازالته من هذا المكان من
اجل الوقوف على كل الحيثيات
وكل صوره واضحه واكيده بشان عمليه
الاستهداف التي تمت في هذه الشقه وهي
كنايه عن مكتب تابع لحركه حماس هنا في
الضاحيه الجنوبيه لبيروت كما بات معلوما
ان مسيره اسرائيليه كانت في الاجواء وجهت
اكثر من صاروخ باتجاه هذه الشقه وهذا
المكتب التابع لحركه حماس في حضور صالح
العاروري نائب رئيس رس المكتب السياسي
وايضا افراد اخرين من بينهم اثنين من
كتائب القسام بحسب المعلومات الوارده حتى
هذه اللحظه طبعا هناك اضرار كبيره في هذا
المكان في هذا المبنى الذي استهدف في
الشارع المحيط وطبعا كما ذكرت عمليات
الكشف والمسح مستمره من قبل الاجهزه
المعنيه داخل الشقه المستهدفه وداخل
المكتب المستهدف لحركه حماس وايضا في كافه
الشوارع القريبه من هنا طبعا بحسب
المشاهدات الميدانيه الجيش اللبناني
والاجهزه المعنيه الامنيه اللبنانيه قطعت
كل الطرقات المؤديه الى هذا المكان والتي
تؤدي الى هذا المكان من اجل القيام بما
يلزم على المستوى الميداني وكما ذكرت رفع
كل الادله وكل ما من شانه ان يؤشر الى
المعطيات الاساسيه التي حصلت المصادر
الطبيه الرسميه تتحدث عن هذه اللحظه او
حتى هذه اللحظه عن سقوط ثلاثه اشخاص ك
ضحايا واستشهاد ثلاثه اشخاص في هذا
التفجير وهذه العمليه التي حصلت في هذا
المكان بالاضافه الى عدد من الضحايا طبعا
ننتظر مزيد من التفاصيل والبيانات الرسميه
التي تصدر عن وزاره الصحه اللبنانيه بشكل
محدد في هذا الخصوص بشان عدد الضحايا
والخسائر البشريه جراء هذا الانفجار طبعا
هناك متابعه حثيثه من قبل الاجهزه الامنيه
المعنيه وطبعا من قبل الجهات الرسميه ال
اللبنانيه الجميع الان طبعا يرصد ويتابع
كيف سيتطور المشهد في المرحله المقبله ليس
فقط على المستوى الميداني هنا في هذا
الشارع الذي وقع فيه التفجير لناحيه
الادله التي سترفع ولكن ايضا على المستوى
الامني اكان جبهه جنوب لبنان وكيفيه
تحركها ربطا بهذا التفجير وهي كما كان
اعلن حزب الله في الاسابيع الماضيه هي
جبهه مسانده وجبهه دعم لقطاع غزه وايضا
المواقف التي سيعلن عنها الامين العام
لحزب الله حسن نصر الله في اطلالته
المقرره يوم غد وهو كان كرر اكثر من مره
ان اي استهداف لاي شخصيه لبنانيه كانت ام
فلسطينيه او تحمل الجسيه اخرى على الارض
اللبنانيه طبعا سيكون له رد وسيكون
طبعا له رد فعل من قبل حزب الله على وجه
التحديد ونحن نتحدث طبعا اليوم عن اغتيال
شخصيه قياديه في حركه حماس في قلب الضاحيه
الجنوبيه لبيروت في هذه المنطقه التي
تعتبر المعقل الاساسي لحزب الله داخل
العاصمه اللبنانيه بيروت وهي كما هو واضح
هي منطقه سكنيه ومنطقه تجاريه بامتياز
وبالتالي هذا الاستهداف الذي حصل هنا كما
هو واضح ادى الى اضرار كبيره في هذه
المنطقه في المبنى الذي تم استهداف مكتب
حماس فيه وايضا في الشارع المحيط الموقف
السياسي الذي صدر حتى هذه اللحظه من قبل
الاجهزه الرسميه اللبنانيه جاء على لسان
رئيس حكومه تصريف الاعمال نجيب مقاطي الذي
قال ان ما حصل هو جريمه اسرائيليه هدفها
توريط لبنان ودعا طبعا الى تطبيق القرارات
الدوليه ومن بينها القرار الدولي
1701 وابرزها طبعا القرار الدولي
1701 الذي كان انهى الاعمال القتاليه في
تموز 2006 اذا هذا هو المشهد هنا عمليات
رفع الا انقاد ورفع الادله مستمره طوق
امني وطبعا قلق في الشارع اللبناني وهذا
تحديدا سنسال بشانه عن الاجواء في الشارع
اللبناني ااء عمليه الاغتيال نشير الى ان
حركه حماس اعلنت استشهاد صالح العرور
واثنين من قاده القسام بعمليه اغتيال
بمسيره اسرائيليه في ضاحيه بيروت الجنوبيه
اي جوني ب بالنسبه لما تتابعه ميد
على
الارض اعداد الشهداء هناك صالح العاروري
واثنان من قاده كتائب القسام هل هناك
مدنيون لبنانيون تاكد استشهادهم ايضا
وماذا عن اجواء الشارع اللبناني في ضوء
التخوفات من ردود الافعال ازاء عمليه
الاغتيال في الواقع حسن قبل الاجابه على
هذه الاسئله لابد من الاشاره الى ان
المكتب الاعلامي لرئيس حكومه تصريف
الاعمال نجيب مقاض اصدر بيانا قبل لحظات
قليله اكد فيه ان مقاطي طلب من وزير
الخارجيه والمغتربين في حكومه تصريف
الاعمال عبد الله بو حبيب تقديم شكوى
عاجله الى مجلس الامن الدولي على خلفيه ما
سماه مقاطي الاستهداف الفاضح للسياده
اللبنانيه من خلال التفجير الذي وقع في
الضاحيه الجنوبيه لبيروت مساء هذا اليوم
وكل الخروق الاسرائيليه المستجده للسياده
اللبنانيه وهذا اجراء غالبا ما يلجا اليه
لبنان عند كل خرق يقوم به الجانب
الاسرائيلي بالنسبه لاعداد الشهداء
المصادر الطبيه حتى هذه اللحظه تتحدث عن
ثلاثه شهداء بشكل مؤكد نتحدث عن صالح
العاروري واثنين من قاده كتائب القسام لم
تعلن الهويات بشكل واضح قد تكون الاعداد
اكبر من ذلك طبعا هذا ما يمكن ان تظهره
الساعات المقبله من خلال البيانات
والاحصاءات التي تقوم بها على وجه التحديد
الاجهزه الاسعافيه ووزاره الصحه اللبنانيه
قد نكون في المرحله المقبله امام بيان
واضح من جانب وزاره الصحه اللبنانيه يتحدث
عن اعداد الشهداء واعداد الجرحى وجنسياتهم
وهوياتهم